continental tire coaches corner today
he's the Rockets head coach Mike
D'Antoni coach good morning how are you
I damn pretty good are you I'm good but
we have a big question a tough question
for you and okay how do you pronounce
your last name damn Tony so where it
looks well we didn't know if it was
D'Antoni yeah yeah the tides of all I
know is when I was in Italy for 21 years
the tires called it they had talked so
I'm going with them what was the best
part about playing in Italy just there
are so many parts probably the situation
that I had it a lot apart from you know
living there which is a super city but
just a teammates and the organization
and is like a college atmosphere yet
they paid you and yet you live to europe
and travel around so just a lot of great
things were you a hero over there a
superstar ah in my mind what did you
Avril did you have the green light did
to do whatever you wanted you know what
I don't even know and that's what's good
about Europe they never paid you one
stats a page if you want a lot matter of
fact they literally paid you if you want
everybody say if you did with but they
didn't I don't even know and I doesn't
matter and it shouldn't matter here
either but you know for different
reasons it matters too much what if what
if we did that here where you got paid
if you want we've got paid more if you
want you would see some exciting has
always thought that you know I have a
base salary for everybody exact same and
then you have bonus over every game you
with you would see some you see some
unbelievable regular season december
15th game it would be great and the
stars wouldn't be sitting out those
games now there would be an issue
interesting thanks song now I don't
think gonna be an issue at all use your
fire you find out there's an upside but
also with the style that you play that
you have employed in all your stops here
was that was that European base at all
like how did you come up with this style
of offense well you know not really in a
sense that
playing the seventies back in the NBA
ABA and that's kind of how you played
without da butt out the three points I
line obviously without the floor being
able to space it players progressed and
it was just a natural evolution of
changing things up a little bit but you
know when I was in Europe and coaching
they claimed I was playing too much like
the Americans just hoist and stuff off
and then when I came here I was like the
European so he's basically growing up in
West Virginia and we ran a run we ran a
guns and Marshall we did the same thing
ABA we did the same thing a MBA you know
this is infinity they all just the
players evolved to where it made sense
to take more threes or to be able to
spread the Floyd gang you know then they
change the rules where you couldn't hand
check so now you can't hardly guard on
the perimeter so if you can't guard on
the perimeter while as you go inside so
much and have people beat you up it
started then it started not making sense
any without to play the way that most of
legs plan now what is the philosophy for
somebody who may not be familiar with
your coaching style how would you do it
in the Cliff Notes version well we just
try to get layups foul shots and threes
and everybody knows there's in between
games and it's always going to be pure
but our offensive set up that those are
three things we want we try to maximize
the space knee and the speed of the game
to get us to the rim or threes or layups
now every player has their own unique
abilities and we try to adjust a little
bit but I'm not going to set up my off
as to where I guys going to come off for
a two-point mid-range shot it just
doesn't make any sense to it will happen
some but it doesn't make any sense for
me that's why that's were shot
basketball so why would you actively
seek it out talking to Mike D'Antoni the
Rockets head coach joining a Stan
Patrick show what did you take away from
the experiences albeit negative with the
Knicks and the Lakers
you know what everything there is some
great things I co some great great
players in the sense of good guy and
then guys wanting to where you're doing
on the biggest stages I know it didn't
work out and I know that no I wish it
would have been better for everybody but
it would I wouldn't change the lin
sanity for anything I wouldn't in che I
would change coaching David Lee I
wouldn't change you know just certain
players that you know why you had a bond
with and I wouldn't change that for
anything but you also have to deal with
superstars sometimes it works sometimes
it does it didn't work with melo or Kobe
but it works with James Harden what's
the difference well I think every every
situation is unique and with Kobe a lot
of injuries and team was a little bit
dysfunctional when I got there and we
couldn't get over the injury bug to make
it functional although we did make the
playoffs and you know people forget Toby
had a great statistical year I want his
best efficient wise and the last 30
games when he was really healthy and we
had other injuries for the last 40 games
we were like 32 and to the 10 last half
of the season so you know there were
some good parts in there just the Lakers
were used to winning every year every
day and so wasn't good enough and we
just weren't good enough and then the
New York thing was was good we had Lynn
sandy going on with a young team we were
six in the in the league my third year
and going up and then we make a trade in
the middle of the year where we
devastated a team we gave up half the
starters if not more and try to bounce
back quickly is just it wasn't realistic
yeah it's it's a strange mix that
delicate mix but even watching that
Phoenix Suns team you did have stars but
you had everybody who sort of bought in
did Brad but but it had to work with
steve nash and but i found what i found
interesting with nash's you had to tell
him to shoot more it's is that true oh
yeah well I wasn't even I should have
told me more i was kind of simple to
after we take you know back then he took
33s on the game people looking at you
cross-eyed say you can't win that way so
you know we didn't have enough data oh I
didn't have enough confidence to go
ahead
and force my will to make it even you
know push the envelope a little bit
further out but Steve Nash would would
do anything that he he was a team-first
kind of guy always and sometimes yet we
had to push him to shoot more no doubt
about he's probably one of the shooters
ever play the game so you know that was
probably my fault too where we didn't
push off love more and it paid and did
he give you at least a hand or a finger
from one of those mbps would the fitting
of a finger again no he should get you
like they'll index finger but let's say
your style there was the middle figure
yeah you know I a look he is one of the
best players and he deserved everything
he got he he had a couple years but I'm
telling you I don't know how many
decision as a point guard especially
anything yet for all the time it's just
a handful of bad decisions the whole
year and he was incredible and he no one
deserves it more than hell and I that
was probably one of the happiest times
I've ever coaches to be a part of that
but he he was going to be great no
matter what the team lined up perfect
for him and he he did he exploited
exactly the BBM 82 years in a row and he
did some incredible things although
Shack still upset about that Coach is a
big the scouting report on Westbrook is
one just you know you got to get by a
game out transition if it's possible
there's a lot of that depends on our
office we don't turn it over we make
shots keeps them out of transition
that's one thing you try to build a wall
we got a garden with five guys and take
liberties off other guys on the floor
maybe they make shots maybe the dull but
the only way you have a chance that not
guarding ruins burg but the limit is
productivity is to have a wall and
behind the guy trying to guard it Pam
ever does an unbelievable job but just
being there and being persistent on what
he does but it's going to be a team
thing and he's going to do the best you
can and having said that he can still go
on but I think it's the only way that we
have a chance who
he remind you of westboro I don't know
if he's ever been naturally like that in
in the lake I don't know I don't know if
except perhaps ever happen for you so
much athletic counted as he retired you
have it's a triple double the way he
goes amiss it it was incredible what he
did this year no doubt about it so I
think he's kind of unique he's like most
players that are their level they're a
blend of different guys and the speed
the strength the stamina you know it's
you put a lot of guys at him yeah it's
like a Jason Kidd you know kid never
stopped and he was just so good from
right you know he's so fast with the
ball but Westbrook could be a defensive
back in the NFL I mean that they're just
Oh his ability to keep coming and he
never stops let me I'll leave you with
this coach and it this isn't an easy
question but let's say you're not
coaching the rockets and you're an
analyst and you're going to size up
James Harden and Russell Westbrook for
MVP what would what would be the
difference in tipping the scales for who
would be the MVP if you're an analyst
now step away if your name yes
definitely rocket all right all due
respect Russell who I think some of the
best players we've ever seen and what he
does is amazing and I love James so so I
am biased and it's hard to say well I'm
an analyst and I could stay awake now
that's hard to do bucket if I was sizing
it up just the efficiency of James the
number of points that he has created on
his team compared to the other guy and
the number of wins and what did what he
means to offense and what he does now
James has a lot I mean I Russell has a
lot of that no doubt but the efficiency
of James and making other guys better
because he's made these guys but he's
made these guys I he has passed if you
look at his back just break down any
pick-and-roll and watch it pass it goes
the weak side and watch where the ball
hits the player it hits him right in the
chest every time and other guys might
make that pass but I might be down the
knees and might be up a little bit and
their percentage goes down every time
the ball moves off that line it goes
down
there too and he delivers it
unbelievable so to me he's the best he's
the best I've ever seen that certain
aspects of the game and he does it very
efficiently and that's that's why I
think he's the most badly player who
runs the point better hard in your niche
because he is so peaceful about I'm not
sure about coach congratulations on the
success and clearing up how to pronounce
your last name very important for us now
here's the hens eggs don't have only 65
years old under this year by my job I
had to wait till you get another head
coaching job there coach there you go
operas to hit up Congrats Thank like
that so Mike D'Antoni played college
basketball at Marshall Marshall a great
college player and then was in Italy I
don't remember him playing in the ABA
but I I remember him in college is being
a great score there yes both would that
be if you didn't make the NBA if you
were like a journeyman overseas that
seems like a great life they pay for
your room they tap the money's tax-free
let you get paid to win that that's an
interesting concept not that the players
the NBA Players Association would go for
that but it is an interesting take on it
continental tire coaches corner
Continental Tire proud to be the
exclusive tire of the Dan Patrick show
no matter what you drive where you drive
continental designs tires for what you
do for more information visit
Continental Tire calm continental tire
for what you do by the way the third
take on the commercial continental tire
is when i made the bank shot from
three-point range just letting you know
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience